I'm here with Matt Welch the
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine for
our look at the current issue so Gary
Johnson is on the cover can this man get
one percent of the vote did he almost
here ounded up he got one point zero
percent i think it's zero point nine
five percent he got the most raw number
of votes in libertarian party history
he's disappointed we've talked to him
since on the website now we have
interview garrett quinn did with him he
was hoping to get maybe two percent but
most people were basically saying it'd
be good to have it at around one percent
so he at least hit that target and for
the first time since 1988 as weird as
this sounds this is the first time that
the Libertarian Party is the third
highest vote getter in the presidential
election let's talk about Benghazi your
column free speech in this country is it
a really dangerous time for free speech
the administration has systematically
lied about that incident over and over
again and has systematically scapegoated
it about this film or this trailer for a
film called innocence of Muslims right
away you know you had Jay Carney saying
we haven't heard anything about this
being a coordinated attack we have no
intelligence to suggest any of that but
you know this was in response to a very
offensive and hateful video this to me
is both a scapegoating exercise and it
it gives into the sort of writers mito
you know if you want to get American
politicians to condemn blasphemous acts
the lesson is burn something down and
they will start doing that Barack Obama
gave a speech in front of the United
Nations about two weeks after all this
happened in which he did make some
limited and good defenses of us system
of free speech we don't control these
things and we're not in the business
theoretically of locking these people up
who say things that we don't agree with
but there is a big but in this which is
that we must all condemn blasphemy in
all of its forms we must condemn you
know bigotry and these things every time
that we encounter it well no you know
that is not appropriate for any
politician to say there is no must when
it comes to free speech the whole point
of it is to be able to blaspheme and
people who want to pass anti-blasphemy
loss and there's a big move worldwide to
do these to assign you and charters
against blasphemy those laws end up
prosecuting those who are religious
minorities and so it very dangerous if
you're walking down the street somewhere
in Western Europe and you stub your toe
and say Jesus Christ can you arrest no
but if you know but if you are in France
and you say the Armenian Genocide didn't
happen you can get arrested if you
denied the Holocaust in any way shape or
form you can get arrested there are
people prosecuted in Canada for printing
the Danish cartoon showing Mohammed I
mean it's incredible what has happened a
nun illegal way and you had a lot of
American academics in the wake of the
latest Benghazi thing saying you know
what our free speech maybe it's a little
bit too absolute we need to think about
how the rest of the world feels and all
this kind of stuff it's time for people
who care about free expression to resist
against that because free expression is
the building block from which everything
else good in life tumbles I mean that's
that's the scientific method it is
everything that's been great since 1800
the cornerstone of that is free
expression we can't sacrifice that
because we think that we're afraid of
some people we don't understand and
people can read all about that and the
most recent issue of reason thank you
very much Matt Welch I don't know any
for reason TV I'm Kennedy
you